what about these these look major to you
sorry
I'm a trainer so uh it's kind of the
house that coach built right here what
are we looking at here that's baby
smooth this is LLS
ladies love Schmidt what what did you
just say go put a dollar in the jar
right now are you serious yeah now damn
it
it's just
please put your shirt back on please
don't make me laugh at you can I hit you
up with some tea
oh my God how good is that for real what
little p mentee yum right
hot sweet
little tea bag action
and it wasn't
I wasn't talking about there it is
oh Jess I just found a Groupon for
hypnosis lessons think about what you
can do with that
sex stuff jar
look guys has anyone seen my good pea
coat John have you seen my sharkskin
laptop sleeve jar
it does anyone see my croquet cleats
hey Jess have you seen my other
timepiece
Nick I came up with the best name for an
uncircumcised penis bishop and a
turtleneck yeah jar
damn it I can't find my driving
moccasins anywhere so you cooking a
frittata in a saucepan what is this
prison sure yeah I know I already got
the money ready Sadie before you leave
can I just ask you a few questions I
know where this is going you are a
gynecologist and a lesbian which makes
you well I'm a genius I know my way
around to Grizzly Adams you too jar as
an adult male I would like to ask you a
few questions about you know the
downstairs girl cookie jar stars all
around jar well the only thing he left
was my summer suit with the lightning
bolt on the back I keep that in my
summer bin along with my summer condoms
Citrus flavored for more refreshing
summer experience jar for sure yeah
you remember this
looks like it's finally interested two
of us huh oh God you're about to say
something stupid aren't you
girl
I'm gonna marry you
jar
I know this might seem crazy and
probably a little bit impulsive but it's
not
not for me
I've known since the minute that I met
you
oh my God Cecilia Perry I'm glad you're
gonna say something stupid aren't you
girl will you marry me
would you please shut up I can't hear
the answer
yes yes
we're getting married
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]